okay here's the scene you're driving
home from work Oh safe and sound trying
to get back to your bowl of popcorn and
your episode of Glee but you hear a
crackle on the radio the crazed what
stabber has escaped from Arkham Asylum
but it's not bad he can't be in your
area you walk in your front door going I
can't be stabbed multiple times in the
but too late he's in your house and you
die dead from multiple stab wounds to
the butt and that's this game oh he
knows that
okay so did you get all that alright
that's not entirely true but there is
someone in the house here at the front
of the house it's still raining hard
better get inside quickly we'll go ahead
is the front door there doesn't seem to
be any lights on inside you can see the
door is slightly ajar is it a good idea
to just go barreling in the front door
the doorbell is not working well that's
that's good I guess
let's go hi Oh what what do you mean
wait a minute don't stab me in the back
get out of there
maybe there's another way I can enter
the house wait a minute was there a
thing to another thing to fight I'm
coming to get yo screams like well that
didn't turn out well
what oh I lost a heart oh I'm like Linc
I got alright the intruder is still
close by it's too dark and dangerous to
carry on from here
Wow hey is that some what I see does
that tell what I see over there why
would he stabbed me and then go away hmm
very strange the butt stabber works in
mysterious ways
okay let's see if we can go around the
back you're getting quite wet now better
find some shelter before you can catch
your breath the garage doors are
unlocked taking a battery got a box with
another battery in it take a radio
don't put the batteries in the radio no
I didn't want to do that no go back go
back in it's probably more stuff in the
garage that I need
hello various bits of junk hello hello
there's nothing else worth having here
oh okay well I wish I had known that
earlier so I just needed the batteries
really all right to the back porch where
the crazed but Statler won't be able to
kill me dead seems like a safer place
than to the house got a flashlight
yeah cool got a flashlight how does that
help me won't that alert the butt
stabber to my position to the kitchen to
the laundry to the bathroom he's going
the bathroom no do I need to go yeah I'm
sure
Hey damn you in the butt well I was
going to the bathroom
ah the crazy bunch stabber knows no
limits that's hilarious exit yeah like a
cat yeah that's the stuff yeah just a
cat yes the kitty cat cuz ha ha ha it
actually worked
ha take that in your face what is he
here for anyway the can of kitty bits
does that mean it's full of bits of
kitty or does that mean it's full of
bits of food for kitty that's the
question where this is where Scott and
Sarah keep their cat looks like he's
been at the garbage bag GARP I spilled
all over the floor is it weird that I'm
seeing like faces in the darkness no I
think that's perfectly intentionally
right there there's a face on that
garbage bag and there's a face right
there and there's a face right there and
there's kind of a face down there was
that supposed to be happening
ok can I go back I don't think there's
anything here that I need right no no no
no no let's go out hey mister intruder
didn't know that I can confuse the
crazed but stabber
with some yelling oh that knife yeah I'm
now armed I can fight back you son of a
[ __ ] yeah you like some tabs into what
we're gonna just be stabbing each
other's butt you son of a [ __ ] what was
that all about
Tyler there is something marked on it
well I'm sure this is important Sarah's
birthday oh good oh good
whoa maybe this is just a surprise
birthday party and they're trying to cut
the cake and someone got confused and
thought I was the cake or rather my butt
was the cake ok
oh he's right there what am i doing you
doing don't open that squeaky to the
pantry I can barely see anything going
on here if there's something that were
whether I just do oh that's a key oh the
combination is I'm gonna turn around is
gonna be right there
why am I still in the house why wouldn't
I go like home or something
he's got back to me well now it's the
perfect time to stab him yeah hi hey
how's it going friendly yes mistake what
part of quiet don't you understand
well screw you game I'm trying my best
I've gotten multiple but stab wounds and
I can't carry on okay
so let's do this correctly we now know
what we need to do is not go in the
front door we're gonna be so quiet so
quiet that no one no one is gonna be
stabbed in the boy
pick up the battery pick up the battery
there's nothing else of value in here
okay got the batteries going now it's
all sneaky sneaky quiet like I can't
believe the the meowing like a cat that
actually worked that of all things
actually worked I can't see anything so
let's see the bathroom he's I'm not
gonna go to the bathroom and he's not
gonna stab me in a but nothing much to
do in here except well you know I don't
know what do you mean what do you mean I
don't know okay to the laundry whoa was
that
they're about to stab over there yeah
like a cat for some reason this guy is
so psycho bonkers crazy
I do a register as a thing good good
good
now that is there anything yep these
faces are just staring that is
definitely a face that is not okay
whatever I don't think that there's
actually in here anything that I need so
let's go around what the hell cat you
can't give me twice you son of a [ __ ]
God that cat scarier than an intruder
there's a face right there - you can't
tell me there's not okay what am i doing
what am I where am I there's no idea
where I am no I was in the laundry room
that's how smokes happened I thought it
was happening when I got to the kitchen
oh never mind
see laundry kitchen back outside or we
gotta go to the kitchen get the chef's
knife so I can fight back he's not there
right now oh this is so dynamic oh wait
a minute the combination the birthday
that's gotta be it that's got to be at
the combination oh the 20th of what
month what is this October
this is the 20th of October sets over
ten twenty wait 102 oh whoa no - oh yeah
so where was that
where was that locked door oh wait he's
not there he's there there okay 102 oh I
think it's a combination for that 10 20
100 down one no 102 Oh
go yeah I did it oh it's easy
oh I don't want to go down there oh that
seems like a bunch stabbers lair who a
wine cellar click to return power to the
house
[Music]
why stairs lead out of the pantry
there's nothing on the stairs no I don't
think so okay let's try this we're doing
uh meow like a cat
you no longer need your flashlight I
think that might be a problematic for me
why didn't I just go out and call the
police
that is it secret
okay he's not there now he okay heard
the noise I heard a noise I heard a
noise
somehow I like it even less when the
lights are on I don't want to watch TV
why are you the evil wizard that stole
my but in the last one I knew that was
gonna happen I don't have infinite
number of hearts man let's see two rooms
lead to the left and right I mean
there's so many rooms there are two
rooms
you're right go get it
I don't have heavy artillery what he
made heavy artillery do I need like a
shotgun or something okay let's go back
to the office
okay that guy's dead oh no meow meow oh
no poor Scott looks like the intruder
got him from behind
okay take a closer look at the drawer to
open the oh wait no what's the new
message on the phone read
are you okay lock myself in our bedroom
get the other gun from the office drawer
and protect yourself I love you well
that's not good so Sarah's in the house
uh-oh so the office drawer where's the
Offutt where's the office drawer wait
hang on there's a lot of messages dinner
at our place
Sarah's phone pick the kids up oh man
Scott cannot find the Kenneth file see
thanks Todd I'm in town a few days we
should catch up is this Todd I haven't
seen the kids see Sarah home late
takeout love you Pete who's Pete fancy
watching a game
Scott kids arrived here safe and sound
we'll drop them off back to your
Saturday evening and then okay so this
isn't good so now just an order any pen
are you sure about that let's see what
what you can't be why do I have to do
this
why is this the thing I've done these
before it's horrible I it ends horribly
this seems highly illogical Scott why
would you be doing this when there's an
intruder in the house Scott maybe you
deserve to die no I mean I don't want to
be harsh but I mean what why why would
that even be a thing just leave it where
it is not like it's gonna care whatever
maybe I could pry it open with what see
drag-and-drop pry it open
bow down I'm gonna get a gun blank
bullets blanks okay there we go
reel click the gun to arm yourself at
any time all right miss
intruder man you crazed what stabber
let's see how you deal with bullets to
deflect and face mostly in the face I'm
gonna shoot you a lot in the face I'm
really gonna shoot you mostly in the
face and not at your butt at all that's
what I'm gonna do Yeah right right I
shot the crap out of him I shot the crap
out of him did he you've taken a hit but
you're okay being true Durr is wounded
and has left you for dead what I shot up
like five times
Oh his blood is is one weakness I should
have been shooting him in his butt your
shooting arm is a little weak but you
must end this now one last shot to the
head we'll do it okay that makes sense
no oh I'm not gonna where'd he go
where'd he go where'd he go but he's not
here now well where is he
where did he go yeah take that intruder
man alright so they got a key the
intruder is dead taking the key okay all
right okay all right okay
finally this horrible chapter of the
bunch dabber is at an end
okay wait a minute what is this what is
this key go to must go something to one
of these rooms here's got to be locked
I'm gonna find someone gotta find
someone okay where do I to Scott and
Sara's bedroom wait a minute there was
now open
stay where you are no no Jimmy now I'm
here knob out it's me markiplier
[Music]
syria's delirious was blinded my pen and
she doesn't recognize who you are see
Leonard shoot me tackle her al face
what what what happened what happened
where's she bleeding from her abdomen
what did I tackle her with a machete
attacking Sarah only compounded or fear
that you were the intruder during a
result in total you accidentally should
be dead
what why how is that a thing tell you in
the frickin face his butt is is one
weakness I really should have shot him
in the butt I I really should him your
text here max 500 characters okay wait a
minute not noticing that doesn't seem
hang on I'm gonna leave I'm gonna replay
the last scene to see if I can do
something you better make sure they're
dead it's okay Sarah it's okay you can
shoot me
ah she shot me I can't believe [ __ ] oh
wait what did she did she shoot me
Sara's gun was loaded with blanks
remember the empty box in the office
drawer you've both come out of this
unharmed
hey where did she get a gun though why
did she make Scott go out and get a gun
if she had one Oh probably cos it was
only loaded with blanks okay just make
some now and cat sounds and you'll be
off and running so either way word to
the wise if you ever shoot someone five
times in the chest twice in the face
roll them up in a carpet soak it in
gasoline light it on fire roll it down a
hill of glass shards into a pool of
sharks and then blow it up with an atom
bomb you better make sure they're dead
so anyway that was intruder hope you
enjoyed it that was actually pretty fun
I really liked it it had some jumps in
there but also it was just kind of a
really well-made flash game I liked it a
lot hope you did too so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
videos I've done and as always I will
see you
who's that I think he's like a clown or
something
I'm awfully lucky that I managed to get
that on the first try
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so the blue is 300 I didn't see any
red numbers